le vélo s'impose et pourrait être le
phénomène de l'été ça va être le cas
tout l'été ça va exploser et ses propres
à montréal 1 c'est propre c'est la même
réalité dans des villes américaines dans
des villes européennes à montréal
l'achalandage enregistré par certaines
bornes a bondi en fin de semaine
dimanche sur le pont jacques cartier par
exemple 4165 passage de cyclistes ont
été enregistrés comparativement à 1 913
à pareille date l'an dernier où le temps
était tout aussi clément il ya une
augmentation d'achalandage mais des
heurts qui sont complètement différentes
de la normale il y a les nouveaux
adeptes et ceux qui renoue avec le sport
à cause du contexte qu vide
en fait j'ai été à quelques années parce
que je trouve qu'il ya trop de monde sur
les pistes cyclables mais avec la
nouvelle réalité bungert comment sa
femme jeune ou mais difficile parfois de
respecter les mesures sanitaires
c'est plein plein plein plein quand
l'école est l'un sur l'autre en panne
schéma de m il ya plus de monde mais
aussi beaucoup de noms à pied en fait
donc que l'on veut vraiment faire du
vélo qu'on se déplace pour vrai avait
l'aube
c'est un peu plus compliqué causes
exactes et un vaste réseau de rues
offrant plus d'espacé pour les piétons
et les cyclistes
c'est justement pour favoriser cette
cohabitation que la ville de montréal
annoncé vendredi dernier
l'ajout de 327 km de voies piétonnes et
cyclables cet été ce conseiller qui
brûle
dans les commerces aussi l'entousiasme
et vif ça explose les ventes ici de vélo
comme de réparation à l'arrière c'est
extraordinaire nous entre samuel fillion
estime que les ventes ont doublé par
rapport aux années précédentes si bien
qu'il craint une rupture de stock
ce qu'on aimerait même engouement chez
vélo serré qu'à québec pour les vélos
haut de gamme et électriques avec les
voyages annulés
le vélo est devenue l'alternative pour
plusieurs il les gens veulent investir
dans leurs nouvelles vacances qui vont
être mais on reste à la maison et on va
faire du vélo et on va faire du camping
reste à voir si le regain de popularité
sera passager si jacques andré
charbonneau radio canada
mon frère